what sort of crazy stuff you know have
you seen because I had a guy on uh a
couple years ago I don't know if you saw
the podcast interview but he uh he did
what was considered I think dancing bear
parties I don't know if if that's still
used today is that something that you're
familiar with yeah I'm used uh I'm very
familiar with a dancing bear what is a
dancing bear if you know if you can
explain it to our
viewers so um back back in the day um
the dancing bear for my knowledge and
people can correct me if I'm wrong I
didn't dive too deep into the dancing
bear but basically porn meets strippers
and the strippers are um covered in
their face for obvious reasons uh with
whatever silly mask it is and then
there's just a line of girls just
[__] each and every one of
them uh I mean I've been in situations
where at bachette
parties um you know there's a two of of
us or maybe three of us that go in to do
a private
party and I'll name this specific
time where we were all police officers
we went in and uh you know we we role
played you just had our flashlights out
we had the siren
music um handcuffs out all the girls
were they were just loving it and um
so towards the end of the gig they
wanted to go in the private room to do
lap dances and so all three of us all
three entertainers went in to give
private dances in a separate room to
three different
girls and I remember hearing one of the
girls who got a lap
dance um was talking about her
husband and they've been married and
they have
kids and so she got a private lap dance
no big deal just a lap dance
um it just more intimate away from the
other girls well that and one thing led
to another and it wasn't me it was
more I am 33 years old now and in my
early 20s I was a lot more wilder than I
am now I'm more tamed um so with the
what
happened basically the
bride um got hot and heavy with the the
other two dancers and ended up having
sex with them and well I was doing the
lap dance with the other girls well I'm
sorry not the bride the girl who was
married okay so the woman that was
married end up sleeping with two of your
colleagues yes and uh the bride was
there but she
wasn't I mean she was
basically halfway oh halfway halfway is
what like in her mouth or I mean use a
little bit of detail and
giving handies um to the guys but she
yeah she didn't have sex with them um
from the last podcast and I I did listen
to uh was it uh Mike yeah the S stripper
yeah yeah U yeah I listen to his podcast
and so so how common is that in your
experience because I mean like I always
get challenged oh that's not that common
you know it's okay if women go to
bachelorette parties like how common was
were indiscretions and women stepping
out on a husband or maybe even you you
know like at a bachor party and it was
the bride to be the next day or
something like that like how often did
that H happen in your
experience you know I will second uh
Mike on this and from my experience
it's it's all comes down to the
influence of the friends
man um they you know encourage the bride
to make some bad decisions if she's not
surrounded with uh you know levelheaded
friends
but it's usually 80% of the time man um
there somebody or just there's a lot of
people that are just wanting to escape
their life in a different state and it's
usually bachette parties from a
different state that come to my home
state or I'll travel and they're from
another state and they're just they
think it's okay because they're they're
far away from home to mess around
weekend they went for long drive they
hopped on a flight they're gone for 2
three days and they figured you know
what happens in Nashville what happens
in Vegas stays in Vegas sort of thing
right yeah okay they got their
girlfriend's egging them on you said 80%
like it's 80% of the time that you'll
see this happen yeah um of the time wow
you know uh I got red pilled um later in
my stripping career because I didn't
really see I I
noticed a lot of uh issues but I just
didn't um the frying pan didn't hit my
head until later um after a two-year
relationship that I was in especially
but
uh yeah usually 80% man and when I do
the performances at an actual
show um you see it constantly you see in
each group of bachette parties and we'll
get maybe like on a busy day um 20 plus
groups or even 50 bat party groups
packed in that uh
venue and uh yeah I mean there's the
guys are usually going home with
somebody or they go out with them and um
just
entertaining the girls just they invite
us too they go out with them out in you
know
downtown and you know as somebody who
notices all this constantly it's
it's it just numbs you as a uh as
somebody who as a man who sees all this
it's just what it is and that's part of
the red
pillings you know you get numbed and but
you just realize okay this is this is
how life actually works I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line book and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out